today is an incredibly worrying time for
many families right across the country
who are concerned about what happens
when they come off fixed term mortgage
deals already people were facing
mortgage payments of 3 000 pounds on
average more than the rates that were
coming
um off of this is going to Heap even
more pain on ordinary Working Families
is why today Labor have set out a
five-point plan to help people with
their mortgages if I was Chancellor
today I would be instructing Banks to
support customers by enabling them for
example to move on to interest-only
products to extend the term of their
mortgage and to hold repossession
proceedings for six months just some
practical things that could be done
right now to help people who through no
fault of their own are facing huge
increases in their mortgage costs it
sounds like you disagree with some other
opposition parties who have been calling
for direct State support to help people
pay their mortgages why do you think
that would be a bad there first of all
we've got to have a targeted scheme
there are people who are particularly
impacted who are really struggling right
now through no fault of their own with
those higher mortgage payments but also
we do have and a huge inflation problem
in the UK and lots of untargeted fiscal
support from the government is not the
right response when we need to tackle
inflation but the targeted approach that
I've set out today with our five-point
plan for dealing with the Tory mortgage
penalty is about getting practical
support right now to those who need it
most if you think now a recession is the
only way to squeeze inflation out of the
system and would that be a price worth
paying I don't agree with that and I
know the worries that families and
businesses are already facing now with
higher energy bills higher food prices
and now the higher mortgages and rents
that are coming our way
um I I Bank need to make the decisions
that they need to make but that's what I
want to ensure that those people who
most need support whether it is through
extending the windfall tax to help with
the cost of living crisis or the
five-point plan for mortgages that we've
set out today that we do everything in
our power and I would as Chancellor do
everything within my power to help those
who need it most I think that's what the
bank is trying to do with this quite
High rate rise though it hit the economy
into recession to try and get inflation
down the bank have got a mandate for
inflation the two percent inflation
Target they need to take the decisions
that they think are appropriate and
unlike the conservatives I'm not going
to give a running commentary on the
bank's decisions it is right that they
have that operational Independence that
the government need to do what only they
can do which is give that instruction to
the financial conduct authority to
ensure that bags are properly helping
customers who at the moment are very
very worried about what these increase
is in interest rates and mortgage rates
mean for them their families keeping a
roof over their head he used to be an
economist at the bank of England do you
think Andrew Bailey's doing a good job
you think you're old colleagues here are
doing a good job handling this
inflationary period
Bank of England's Independence was one
of the greatest achievements of the last
Labor government the conservatives spent
a large proportion of last year
undermining the independence of the bank
of the office of budget responsibility
and of course sacking the former
permanent secretary at the treasury I I
recognize that economic stability of
Financial and physical stability are the
rock upon which all other economic
policies must rest and undermining those
independent Economic Institutions will
only make the challenges that we face in
getting a group of inflation and growing
our economy even harder so I will not
unlike the Tories indulge in that sort
of politics look forward to serving your
first four years in government with
Andrew Bailey in his last four years and
term as Governor there'd be no plans to
change that at all but I'm not being
complacent at all about what happens at
the next election labor will be fighting
for every vote but with me as Chancellor
all of our economic policies will be
built on that rock of economic fiscal
and financial stability